[Music]
welcome back to a windy white house as
we told you earlier immigration will be
a big focus of tonight's State of the
Union address chief congressional
correspondent Mike Emanuel is on Capitol
Hill to tell us where we are right now
on immigration reform
I want the resolve from the President to
make a decision to either tell this
there's going to be something in our
favor or not so-called dreamers young
people brought to this country illegally
by their parents want reassurance from
President Trump Democrats in Congress
are telling them they're here to stay
there is bipartisan support not only
overwhelmingly in the country but
bipartisan support in the Congress
Congress and we will not rest we will
not stop this will not end except
happily for our dreamers some
Republicans question whether Pelosi and
Democrats want a solution or would
prefer to have a political issue in the
midterm elections Senate Republican
leaders say President Trump has made a
serious offer on daca which the majority
leader says has some support from a
major Latino group I hope they do listen
to the leaders of LULAC who said here in
effect that what the president has
offered he's a reasonable proposal that
ought to break the ice that oughta give
us a chance to get an outcome the House
Republican whip emphasized a deal
containing elements critical to GOP
lawmakers you've got to secure the
border you've got to start building the
wall put the technology and tools in
place so that we can actually get back
to rule of law today Speaker Paul Ryan
raised the concern that some Democrats
are solely focused on this one issue and
blocking some other critical business
such as setting spending caps and
rebuilding the military I urge the
Senate Democrats do the right thing
drop the filibuster process of
legislation we want to find a daca
solution we will find a doctor solution
so don't hold up our military funding
hostage for this let's move forward
there's been some question about whether
House Republicans will support a daca
deal senior GOP leaders say if President
Trump backs a particular bill they are
confident a significant number of House
Republicans will get on board
Brett Michael Manuel live on the hill
Mike thanks